how are you i'm good how are you man i'm
good
so i mean the amount of titles you have
in this thing so like co-cr i think
co-creator
writer executive producer actor
clearly you're invested yeah like
like what was the what was this
character that really stood out for you
like you wanted to get this involved in
this
and really bring this to life there were
a lot of things i've always been a fan
of modoc i've always been a fan of
there's a part there's a there's an area
in in marvel comics
it's like the c and d level area of
marvel but it's so
rich in character because it it's it's
more in a weird way it's actually more
human they're resentful
they're jealous they they're they're
they have world dominating plans but
they have
very petty reasons for them they kind of
touch on it a little bit in
um spider-man homecoming with the
vulture i thought michael keaton
was brilliant like no i don't want to
conquer the world i just want a nice
house in the suburbs i want my
daughter to go to a good school like
that's it so
you know that kind of level of of
especially a guy who has this
massive superior intellect but
cannot get out of his own way because he
still keeps that residual
resentment of being this average schlub
you know
mopping the floors of aim for god's
sakes like he's not
like the absolute wrong person to put
that much power into their hands
so that to me just was oh let's please
this is
so great comedically but still
absolutely fits into the marvel universe
right yeah what's it like joining the
marvel universe i mean in terms of like
meetings like is it as like secretive
hush as we all believe it is very very
secretive yeah there's like
private email servers and all kinds of
yeah they
but again they're they're doing it not
out of weirdness
they have that same geek excitement of
we want people to be surprised about
this we don't want this stuff leaked
we're as excited
for you to see it like we they they
remember when they were coming up
waiting for
the next thing to come out maybe little
teases or like they would draw
you know like the shadow of something in
the last panel and next issue
meet you know the whatever and they're
oh my god what's this going to be so
you know they want to keep that
excitement going i i really really
respect that
yeah were you surprised at how non-pg
they let you be um
yeah i mean i would you know there's
something about
3d animation where it kind of cuts the
the
sting a little bit if you're going to be
a little violent or weird because
there's kind of a
silliness to it and also it's like that
jack kirby everything is so
big and bold and thick and you know huge
emotions and
big consequences so it kind of just
makes
the the violence and stuff feels very
monty python-esque where you're like
right yeah over the top you're like oh
okay that's
you know he just blows people's arms off
right and like they have iron man i know
you sound like you're gonna have other
appearances were you surprised that they
let you
like have iron man in this i i don't
want to say anything
more let's just say that there were
people that we asked for that we're like
let's ask for this person so that
they'll give us this person like
those ones as a sacrifice they'll go no
but you can have this one and they said
yes to
everything wow i was
i was stunned they let us play in the
sandbox
yeah now being a super villain in marvel
i'm i doubt you're aware but what was
your reaction to your vip co-star judah
louis dreyfus
all of a sudden joining as a villain in
the marvel universe were you aware in
any kind of way
i had no idea and i and i texted her
that night when i watched that episode i
was like
oh i was like madam hydra are you
kidding me and she was really excited
she goes yeah it goes
this is such a so amazing like do you
realize how
huge of a villain you're playing right
now like that's a big deal
i'm really really excited yeah like i
find it so interesting
like with you getting into the marble
with melissa getting to marlborough with
julia
even katherine han and wanda vision like
what do you make of this like kind of
comedians like real true comedians are
getting into the marvel world now like
you're playing villains
i i don't think it's so much it's the
comedians that
comedians especially know how to play
vulnerability and frustration and
pettiness
which is what it's like the marvel
superheroes
also have very worldly concerns like yes
peter parker is
spider-man but he's worrying about you
know getting a job and i gotta pay for
my school and
yes thor is the god of thunder but he he
literally has like petty family problems
that
the fate of the universe hangs on and
marvel kind of does the same thing with
their villains their villains
can be very petty very personal very
jealous very
vulnerable you know and and also some of
them can have
good qualities which is very weird when
that happens you know there was a
my favorite series was kurt bouziak's
untold tales of spider-man where the
vulture
talks a kid out of committing suicide oh
yeah
does it in a very villainous way like
why would you commit
a moronic act like this whoever is
making you feel this way you need to
destroy them like it like
it's a but he does talk to kids to be
like i guess he just helped that ki like
it was
so like those kind of gray areas i
just love you know i mean um agatha
harkness is not completely evil
in um in in uh uh one division she's
like i need to know how you do this
because i don't think
you should be controlling this power
because you're you're going to destroy
the world like
it was really interesting and later
agatha becomes her mentor
yeah yeah yeah and then and i know if
you saw the trailer this morning like
the
phase four trailer that marvel released
in terms of the films that are
coming out like you have great
representation in this show in terms of
latina
uh in terms of melissa's character being
bisexual but yeah we're seeing
like marvel really expand in terms of
its representation even into the
comedic side of stuff like what does it
feel like to be part of this new
phase of marvel that they're doing um it
feels
it feels amazing but i would argue that
yes it's very new what marvel's doing in
terms of inclusivity and
um diversity in their films but this was
sort of the foundation that marvel was
built on when it started because back
then
in the comic industry i don't think that
they cared if someone was a woman or an
african-american or
they were just like we need the best
artists we need writers that can we just
need
people that are good so in a weird way
the rooms
were the beginnings of that diversity of
it doesn't matter who's in the we just
need the best people we can get and then
it's slowly it took way longer to
translate into
the comics themselves and then the tv
shows and the movies but it's
it's been part of a very long arc that
luckily we're getting towards now and
also the fact that
i was very we we made very i made it
very very clear i don't want
the the the fact that that modoc is in a
mixed
marriage and that the daughter is but
that is never a plot point in the
thing it just something that's never
mentioned like no one cares so that's
just that to me is true diversity and
it always hits me like people that are
against diversity or people that are
racist or people that are homophobic
weirdly enough they're fine when someone
in the minority is like fighting for
their rights because you're like see how
angry and crazy they are
it's depicted it was like that one ikea
commercial remember the ikea commercial
it was a gay couple but they had nothing
to do with them being they're just like
buying right
in the house and there was all this
outrage because they're like how dare
you make this normal it's like
because it is normal because we're not
going to even try to get in your face
about it anymore
we've evolved you haven't you it's now
your problem like
you're the one with the problem it's not
us so
that to me was a huge leap forward i
really really wanted to embrace that
it was just like i mean look the fact
that
black panther which was pretty much an
all african-american cast was this
massive blockbuster that everyone went
to see because it's a good movie like
and people just i just want to see a
good movie exactly yeah
the real that's where the real stuff the
real progress comes
yeah i love that you're doing that yeah
it's amazing reminds me through a shit's
creek how like dan liverweight like they
never did that storyline
but they hadn't went
again there's all this really exciting
stuff going on which is why i think that
the people that are so racist and are so
homophobic
are so loud right now because they can
sense that this is the end
when you when your enemy stops fighting
you and just goes just
fine go do whatever i'm just going to go
over here and do my stuff that's when
they really freak out because like you
don't matter
your bigger tree just doesn't even
matter anymore yeah
very well said well congratulations on
the show i saw the first two i can't
wait to see more
oh dude you okay no i can't say anything
i can't see it i'll
all right watch just again everything we
asked for we got
to a point where we were like are they
really gonna i'll tell you
i'll put it this way everything we asked
before we got to the point where then we
got nervous going
well now that we have this it's ours to
screw up so right like
it's so it's like when when you're a
chef and someone goes i'm gonna give you
this wagyu beef it's like well if i
don't cook this right then i'm a
chef right and then it's truly on me you
know what i mean like once they give you
the good ingredients then you've really
got to step
up yeah you'll step up i have no doubt
you'll step up pat
all right thanks a lot for talking to me
today ben all right congratulations
you